Neural networks เป็นกลุ่มของอัลกอริทึม machine learning ที่ทรงพลังมาก
และมีหลายรูปแบบมาก
เราไม่มีทางอธิบาย neural networks ได้อย่างละเอียดพอ
ในวิดีโอแนะนำอย่างนี้
เราจะพูดถึงแค่องค์ประกอบหลักไม่กี่อย่าง
ของ neural network และกระบวนการทำงานโดยรวม
เพื่อให้เข้าใจว่า quantum computing เข้ามามีบทบาทได้อย่างไร
neural network คือกราฟของ neurons ที่เชื่อมต่อกัน
neuron คือสิ่งที่เก็บตัวเลขไว้อย่างง่ายๆ
และตัวเลขนั้นมักเรียกว่า activation ซึ่งบอกว่า
neuron นั้นเปิดหรือปิดแค่ไหน
neurons จะถูกจัดแบ่งออกเป็น layers
layer แรกคือ input layer
และ layer สุดท้ายคือ output layer
ตรงกลางจะมี layers สำหรับประมวลผลที่เรียกว่า
hidden layers ส่วน activation ของ
input layer จะโหลดมาจากข้อมูลที่ต้องการวิเคราะห์โดยตรง
เช่น ความเข้มของพิกเซลในรูปภาพ
activations ของ hidden layer ถัดไปจะถูกกำหนด
โดย neurons ใน input layer
และโดย weights ซึ่งแทนด้วยเส้นที่เชื่อม neurons ทั้งหมด
ใน input layer เข้ากับ neurons ทั้งหมดใน
layer ถัดไป กล่าวคือเราหา activation
ของ neuron ใน hidden layer
จากผลรวมถ่วงน้ำหนักของ
input activations ทั้งหมด เราสามารถ
ใส่ bias เพิ่มเข้าไป ซึ่งก็คือการเลื่อนค่า
เราอาจต้องการให้ neuron
ใน hidden layer ทำงาน ไม่ใช่แค่เมื่อผลรวมถ่วงน้ำหนักเป็น
บวก แต่ต้องเกิน threshold ที่กำหนดไว้ด้วย
จากนั้นเรามักใช้ฟังก์ชันที่ซับซ้อนเพื่อให้ได้ activation
ระหว่างศูนย์กับหนึ่ง เช่น hyperbolic tangent
หรือบางครั้งก็ใช้
rectified linear unit ไม่ต้องกังวลเรื่องนี้มากนัก
ตอนนี้สิ่งสำคัญที่ต้องรู้
เกี่ยวกับฟังก์ชันเหล่านี้มีอยู่อย่างเดียวคือ
มันเป็น nonlinear
เพื่อให้ทั้ง network มีทั้งส่วนที่เป็น linear
และ nonlinear อยู่ด้วยกัน
ผลรวมถ่วงน้ำหนักของ activations แบบเดิม คราวนี้
เริ่มจาก activations ของ
hidden layer แรกกับ weights ใหม่
จะขยายต่อไปยัง hidden layer ถัดไป
กระบวนการนี้ต่อเนื่องไปจนถึง layer สุดท้ายซึ่งเป็น output
output layer มี neurons ที่ตรงกับ
หมวดหมู่ต่างๆ และ activations บอกเรา
ว่า network มั่นใจแค่ไหนในการจำแนกประเภทนั้น
ตัวอย่างเช่น หมวดหมู่ output ในการวิเคราะห์รูปภาพอาจเป็น
หมา แมว แฮมสเตอร์ และอื่นๆ
และถ้า activation ของ
neuron หมาได้ 0.95 ก็แสดงว่ามั่นใจมากว่า
รูปนั้นเป็นรูปหมา เราอาจเริ่มต้น neural network
ด้วย weights แบบสุ่ม
และ biases หรือจากค่าเริ่มต้นที่รู้ว่าสมเหตุสมผล
แต่จากนั้นเป้าหมายคือการตรวจสอบ
ว่า neural network จำแนกสิ่งต่างๆ ได้ดีแค่ไหน
และปรับปรุงมัน เราใช้ cost function เพื่ออธิบาย
ว่า neural network เบี่ยงเบนไปจาก
การจำแนกที่ถูกต้องแค่ไหน โดยการหา
ความแตกต่างระหว่างค่าจริงของรูปภาพ
เช่น ค่าหนึ่งบน neuron
ของหมา และศูนย์บน output neuron อื่นๆ ทั้งหมด
กับค่าที่ทำนายได้
เราบวกรวมทุกหมวดหมู่
จึงติดตามได้ไม่เพียงแค่ว่าหมวดหมู่ที่ถูกต้องถูก
activate มากที่สุดหรือเปล่า แต่เรายัง
ติดตามได้ว่า activations ที่ผิดพลาดลดลงหรือไม่
บวกรวมทุกตัวอย่างใน training set ของเรา
และได้ค่า cost จากนั้นเราก็
ปรับ parameters อย่าง weights ในแต่ละ layer
ระหว่าง neurons ทั้งหมด และ biases ของทุก neuron
กระบวนการ optimisation แบบ classical จะถูกใช้
เพื่อค้นหา local minimum ใน cost function
ถ้าไม่มีอะไรมาช่วยลดความซับซ้อนของสิ่งนี้
ลองนึกภาพดูว่า parameter space
ที่เราสร้างขึ้นมามันใหญ่โตแค่ไหน
ลองดู neural network ที่ออกแบบมาวิเคราะห์รูปภาพ
แค่พันพิกเซล neural network นี้อาจมีพัน
input neurons มี hidden layer เดียว
และ output แบบ binary เช่น แมวหรือหมา
นี่คือกรณีที่ง่ายที่สุดแล้ว
แต่ก็ยังต้องใช้ weights พันคูณพัน
หรือล้าน weights ระหว่าง input กับ hidden layers
และอีกสองพัน weights ระหว่าง
hidden กับ output layers
และอาจมีอีกพัน
กว่า biases ดังนั้น neural network ง่ายๆ นี้ก็ต้องใช้
parameters กว่าล้านตัว แต่ก็ต้องยอมรับว่า
อัลกอริทึมสมัยใหม่มักทำการลดความซับซ้อนลง
ใน classical neural networks อยู่แล้ว
และมีหลายสาขาวิชาที่ทุ่มเทเพื่อทำให้การหา minimum นี้
เป็นไปได้และมีประสิทธิภาพด้วย
แต่ความจริงก็คือนี่ยังคงเป็นปัญหา
ที่มีมิติสูงมาก
และการ train neural network
อาจใช้เวลานานมาก
และมีค่าใช้จ่ายสูง quantum neural network หรือ QNN
ทำงานโดยเริ่มจากการโหลดข้อมูล input
จากนั้นนำ quantum circuits มาใช้
ซึ่งตรงกับ weights ระหว่าง layers
และสุดท้ายคือ layer ของการวัดผล
มีจุดสำคัญไม่กี่อย่างเกี่ยวกับเรื่องนี้ การโหลดข้อมูล
และการถ่วงน้ำหนักเป็นการดำเนินการแบบ linear
แต่การวัดผลนั้น nonlinear
ดังนั้นเหมือนกับใน classical neural networks เรามี
ทั้งส่วน linear และ nonlinear อยู่ด้วยกัน
นอกจากนี้ weight circuits
ยังมี variational parameters อยู่
ดังนั้นยังต้องมีการทำ classical minimisation อยู่ดี
แน่นอนว่านี่เป็นแค่การแตะผิวของ quantum neural
networks แต่เราหวังว่าคุณจะเรียนรู้เรื่อง applications ต่อไป
ของ quantum neural networks
และ quantum machine learning applications อื่นๆ
กับ IBM Quantum